singulièrement bienvenue heures comment
vous sentez vous
remets mon pote le lieutenant veut dire
que ces vieux jeu sans prier
sion quand il revit la statue de la
liberté symbole de la foi américaine
pour la démocratie dont vous demander
quels sont vos projets immédiats le
deuil d'une charge une nana oui c'est à
dire pire à voler vers les cieux pour
retourner sa vieille maman attentionnée
du congrès nous sommes prêts même si je
n'avais pas de taille modeste tous les
fronts de la corde mairie d'être des
rares et on est petit le quality avait
battu le record radio était descendu est
il exact à cette occasion le haut
commandement
ces têtes explosives caisse de champagne
pareil mais manque de pot elle s'est
perdue en eau
comme par hasard mon profond lieutenant
et d'un accident sur sa faim le prix de
la pêche de champagne est mrcg d'euros
ce fonds de secours bruce et clamant
avec mamadou ses avions barbet l'on a bu
l'arbalète
on a mal
l'inculte attribue ses succès d'abord à
l'esprit des types exceptionnelle de
nous sommes ensuite à la chance est
évidemment à la supériorité de notre
matériel parmi nous des japonais des
têtes de l'art de ce à quoi la
différence entre leur nez une pompe à
vélo au lieu de le dire que la qualité
de l'aviation ennemie a décliné et votre
mécano à celui-là alors il est né avec
tous les doigts dans le nez
chaque fois qu'on dit collet sait tenait
du miracle reader ne tarit pas d'éloges
pis si braga titraille n'était jours
dans l'eau pour permettre à nouveau de
s'envoler vers le soleil de la loi il
paraît que vous voulez vous aidera pas y
être construits mais dès que j'ai
peut-être mieux à faire non
pendant toute la durée de sa mission le
ne tenant un emploi dit aux extraits du
monde
extrêmement chargé par les salue
également la fermeture des bars si je
veut draguer de manière convenable
salut c'est à dire que le lieutenant
moderne serait retardé le moment de
goûter à la tarte aux pommes fabriqués
par sa maman de revoir la fiancée qui
l'attend est la grande rue de son
village où il jouait aux indiens quand
il était petit garçon mais je peux
répondre à sa place
si vous avez encore des questions à
poser je répondrais aussi bien qu'il
peut le faire